our robotic host overlords have blessed
us with the season 4 trailer of
westworld and if you've been following
my channel for a while you know i've
been a big fan of the show so let's not
waste any of your time and see what
clues we can gather from this all new
season our first shot is of this
sprawling western vista either we're in
westworld or perhaps some
post-apocalyptic wasteland you can make
out a car on the left-hand side
barreling towards something in the
center it's a bit too blurry to make out
but our next shot is a mave walking down
a paved road so likely not westworld and
i get a total linda hamilton and
terminator vibe here since season one
maeve has been on a quest to reunite
with her daughter who is currently in
the sublime a kind of heaven for hosts
so much of her storyline this season
will likely revolve around that and
here's caleb seemingly back to his old
mundane job something you'll notice is
that this world seems totally fine not
the world on the edge of chaos we left
him in at the end of season 3. some time
has also passed as evidenced by his
beard and if you look really closely
you'll even notice he has what appears
to be a wedding ring the creators of
westworld have said they'd like to
approach each season with something
fresh so it's entirely possible that the
caleb we're seeing here is actually
stuck in a simulation and he's totally
oblivious to it he could also be in a
park run by hosts this is easy to miss
but listen to the words of the song that
plays in the background here
in the park
drink sangria in the park he's drinking
and he may also be in a delos-style park
this would be pretty cool as it would be
a complete 180 from season one instead
of humans coming to westworld and
[ __ ] around with the oblivious hosts
here it's the hosts who control the
oblivious humans it could also be
possible that the uprising at the end of
season 3 was quelled and he's just
keeping a low profile although that
doesn't seem as interesting here we get
our first shot of dolores in front of
this somewhat creepy building it's
pretty cool that she's dropped off in a
white autonomous vehicle she once got
around westworld riding a white horse a
reflection of william here a metaphor
for the reflection of the man he once
was at the end of season 3 it looks as
though the real william is killed and
replaced with a host copy this copy was
only given that super violent data delos
collected of william when he visited the
park so this is a william you don't want
to mess with hey and look who it is
stubs we last saw bleeding in a motel
bathtub so just how did he get from
there to here and how come he didn't
come back for bernard who we saw covered
in dust in some post-apocalyptic future
at the end of season 3. this all
supports the theory that we're either in
a simulation or some park where humans
are the ones held captive stubbs seems
to notice william here and look at that
william has a fully fleshed out hand
remember the real william had his cut
off and it may just be me but it looks
like everyone here is either wearing
black or white dolores emerges from what
could be a train or subway station and
you can make out these excited men
saying can you [ __ ] believe this this
is his first time it's almost as if
they're getting ready to go to one of
the westworld parks you'll notice
dolores is also sporting some new brown
hair suggesting that this is some sort
of different dolores remember at the end
of season 3 her entire memory was wiped
so we aren't quite sure what she's up to
she does however have that same earpiece
she used to communicate with in season
3. now i couldn't really tell what this
thing was but to me i think it could
either be a film role or shotgun shell
delores here alongside season 4 newcomer
ariana debose her role is currently a
secret it looks as though delores is
seeing someone she might remember but
considering this shot is preceded by
that rolling object it gave me season 1
vibes of when teddy or william would
pick up that rolling soup can and give
it to her and here's a gramophone a
victor talking machine to be exact which
were made from 1901-1929
it looks like maeve and caleb are
getting ready to enter a new park one
set in the 1920s we'll even see one of
those orientation rooms where one can
pick out period-appropriate clothing and
weapons this coincides with a shot of a
gangster using a tommy gun to shoot down
a police officer maybe this is this
world's version of hector robbing the
mariposa here we get a better shot of
william at his repaired hand we can't be
certain where he is but it kind of looks
like the underground of the delos
facility where old units are stored away
here's bernard and the sublime looking
at delores's white horse we also get to
see delores's tree one which she
regularly frequented in westworld and it
goes up in flames this isn't some
optimistic foreshadowing here's a bunch
of people learning how to dance
mimicking how the hosts were trained to
dance in westworld when arnold and ford
first started testing them william can
be seen here in the crowd meaning
charlotte hale who you may recall wants
to destroy humanity and at the end of
season 3 was creating hundreds of hosts
in the basement of the delos labs in
dubai it looks like she's telling
william to be quiet as to not interrupt
their dance practice and you'll notice
her arm still carries the burn scars she
wanted to keep these scars as a reminder
of what humanity did to her not exactly
sure who this poor soul is but it looks
as though clementine is in control here
now we get bernard and an unknown
companion in the deserted mesa hub it
looks like it could be around the same
time as the season 2 post-credits scene
featuring william notice how bernard
here is bald it's different than when he
was in the sublime but the same as when
we saw him in the motel if this takes
place around the same time as those
post-credit scenes in season 2 then this
is the farthest in the future the show
has gone according to the showrunners
here charlotte invites william to the
top of that building we see near the end
of the trailer you can see it has the
same g-string type architecture this
appears to be her headquarters just like
westworld had a virtual map in the
middle of the control room it appears
that charlotte has one here of the
surrounding city which once again hints
that she is either running a park or
some sort of simulation this guy isn't
getting the greatest delos park
experience considering the amount of
flies around he's in the pre-park
fitting area where a swarm of flies have
somehow been set loose now this is cool
it looks like william is creating a copy
of himself in a new type of device or
this could actually be the real william
who is cryogenically frozen just like
sorak's brother in season 3. dolores
underwater nothing really to mention
here and what appears to be the
westworld steam train however it looks
extremely dirty it's not looking good
for caleb here who's being hunted down
by a drone host and here we have william
being brought into charlotte's tower
with these red riot robots standing
guard it looks like charlotte has
succeeded in whatever she has taken over
this freaky image is of a robot spewing
flies and maybe that's where these guys
came from could be an early version of
maeve's daughter judging by the inside
mechanics matching the older models
perhaps this robot is used as some sort
of trojan horse to unleash these flies
but we're not quite sure yet what the
purpose of this is here's william
shooting who appears to be lawrence if i
recall lawrence had one of delores's
five pearls inside him and was
responsible for helping bernard acquire
the device allowing him to access the
sublime so it would make sense that this
william under the orders of charlotte
would want lawrence dead we're not quite
sure if we're in westworld here because
notice the pretty modern gun lawrence is
holding this vehicle may also be the
same one found in that wide shot at the
very beginning i couldn't quite make out
this character but it seems whoever it
is is either killing this animal on the
ground or perhaps performing a c-section
which might make more sense considering
the next shot is of another birth of
sorts now there's something about this
that just feels a little off to me is
this machine making a host or a human in
the background you'll notice two chairs
sitting across from one another just
like how the programmers at the parks
would sit across from hosts and ask them
various questions when they first came
online poor bernard can't seem to catch
a break and this guy here has one of
those flies go right into his eye caleb
here in 1920s clothing all bloodied up i
think it's safe to say delos won't be
getting a good yelp review i couldn't
make out who this is but it appears to
be someone holding a bunch of ash here
we have another close-up of eyes perhaps
dolores's since you can make out the
reflection of her tree and what appears
to be a house with a small chimney the
final shot is of the cheese string tower
and there are a few interesting things
here these boxes below look like they
could be homes for the workers as seen
in this shot and check out this really
long bridge connecting the tower complex
to the island it might be a railway in
which people can access whatever [ __ ]
up human park charlotte has created on
the other side whatever this season has
in store i'm totally excited for it and
i hope you'll stick around and subscribe
because i'm hoping to cover the entire
thing thanks for watching everyone make
sure to like and leave a comment on what
you think will happen in season 4. for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember which is how i
know i'm not the only one who can lay a
trap